[Music]
are you celebrating christmas this year
nope are you celebrating kwanzaa nope
well what are you celebrating survive in
2020. that sounds about right
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
okay national christmas tree day was
this week
because there's no more fitting
tradition for 2020 than
unnecessarily killing something
a controversial christmas card from 1843
was put up for sale last week
which features a woman holding a glass
of red wine
up to a child's mouth it's bad but
not as bad as megan kelly's christmas
card
remember when she said that yep he's
white i don't care
he's white and i don't care who knows it
hey megan
huh be black no
what a weird hill to die on but okay
the supreme court this week denied a
request from republicans to overturn the
results of the presidential election in
pennsylvania
issuing a one-sentence denial that
sentence was
boy if you'll get your stupid ass out of
here
let's see if it worked the video live
streaming service twitch has announced
that it will ban
images of the confederate flag blackface
and swastikas
while facebook will start offering them
as filters
[Music]
had to get off facebook i mean
[Applause]
that is actually going to happen you
know it
will zuckerberg's like that's a good
idea
someone at home is like that's a great
way to make a bajillion dollars
74 of people reached by new jersey's
contact tracers have been uncooperative
i'm not surprised people in new jersey
don't cooperate with anything
they don't even cooperate with slaves
i don't believe in them
[Laughter]
what are you talking about arm chokers
look at these guns get out of here
[Laughter]
we found something tarrick and i are bad
at
[Laughter]
new jersey and i'm from new jersey you
are from new jersey it should be
hey this is what we talk like out there
oh
no no i do not think that that is true
actress felicity huffman turned 58 years
old this week but
she got it reduced to 54 years for good
behavior
i feel bad for nothing and finally
according to early research the
coronavirus may be linked to men
developing erectile dysfunction which
can only mean one thing
we'll have a cure for it by tomorrow and
that's it for the monologue
but that's not it for the news cause man
do i have some fun news okay
after tonight we have one more episode
of the amber ruffin show this year
and then guess what we're coming back
after the new year with more episodes
yay i'm so excited hey tarek are you
busy next year
i am now that's what i thought
now the other big news of this week is
that after
months of experiments and clinical
trials new york city will receive its
first
doses of the coronavirus vaccine this
tuesday the city will only receive a few
doses though so they'll be reserved for
i got it what i got the vaccine
sarah that's impossible they're only
giving the first doses to essential
workers
yeah essential workers like healthcare
professionals and nursing home residents
and talk show sidekicks you're not an
essential worker tarik
of course i am my work is essential to
this show if i wasn't here to ambulably
chuckle at your jokes
who knows what would happen watch tell a
joke
the u.s coast guard issued a warning in
hawaii after
over 1 000 shipping containers fell off
of a ship
the warning was hey look out for all
those shipping containers falling off
that ship
okay okay now tell it again
the us coast guard issued a warning in
hawaii after over 1 000 shipping
containers fell off a ship
the warning was hey look out for all
those shipping containers falling off
that ship
okay you're essential thank you
now that that's settled we here at the
amber ruffin show because of the
pandemic
we're stuck in the studio all the time
but this week
we actually have a few extra minutes
so i thought it might be nice to get
outside for once so we're
just gonna go for it it's a segment
called
let's go see new york
[Music]
okay we are going to go outside man this
is gonna be great
we're gonna go see the rockefeller
center christmas tree and maybe we'll
find another baby owl and if we do
i'm gonna name him cletus owls have a
similar wise energy to all black men
so we're gonna go outside i'm so
excited okay so now i haven't been to
times square in like
500 years and it makes me feel seen to
see that elmo that's always in times
square
he looks like he's been through a lot
and i'm always like
girl same because very relatable
okay we are going to go outside maybe
we'll even get on the
subway oh my god i haven't been on the
subway in like 50 years
i actually really miss the adrenaline of
yelling hey
hold that door and then no one holds
anything
okay we are going outside
now if i'm feeling really brave i might
even get a new york hot dog
really have like the full tourist
experience and
ruin my trip by getting food poisoning
we're gonna go outside oh my gosh i
wonder if soho or dumbo house is open
maybe i'll stop by
i miss being told i'm not cool enough to
join and being yelled at for using my
phone okay i'm all ready
now let's go see new york first stop
wait what happened
we ran out of time to do the segment oh
well we must have a few seconds left
right
we do but you're going to need them to
take all that [ __ ] off
[Music]
[Applause]
you